Si vous prenez 10'000 personnes au hasard, 9'999 d'entre elles ont un point commun:
leur intérêt professionnel est situé sur ou près de la surface de la Terre.
Celui qui reste est un astronome, et je fais partie de cette étrange espèce.
(rires)
Mon intervention comporte deux parties. Je vous parlerai d'abord en tant qu'astronome,
puis en tant que membre inquiet de l'espèce humaine.
Mais commençons par nous souvenir que Darwin nous a montré
que nous étions le résultat de 4 milliards d'années d'évolution.
Et ce que nous essayons de faire en astronomie et en cosmologie
c'est de remonter dans le temps avant ce point de départ,
pour replacer la Terre dans un contexte cosmique.
Laissez-moi vous montrer quelques photos.
Ceci est un impact observé la semaine dernière sur une comète.
Si on y avait envoyé une bombe nucléaire, ça aurait été un peu plus spectaculaire
que ce que nous avons observé Lundi dernier.
C'est un autre projet pour la NASA.
Voici Mars vu de la sonde européenne Mars Express, au début de l'année.
Cette image d'artiste est devenue réalité
quand un parachute a alunit sur Titan, la lune géante de Saturne.
Il s'est posé sur la surface. Ces images ont été prises durant la descente.
On dirait une côte en bord de mer.
C'est effectivement cela, mais l'océan est en méthane liquide --
et la température de moins 170°C.
Si on regarde au delà de notre système solaire,
nous avons appris que les étoiles ne sont pas que de petits points de lumière scintillants.
Chacune est un soleil avec son cortège de planètes,
et nous pouvons observer des endroits où des étoiles sont en formation,
comme la Nébuleuse de l'Aigle. Nous voyons des étoiles mourir.
Dans 6 milliards d'années, notre soleil ressemblera à cela.
Certaines étoiles meurent spectaculairement dans une explosion de supernova,
laissant des débrits comme ceux-ci.
A une plus grande échelle encore, nous voyons des galaxies d'étoiles.
Nous voyons des écosystèmes entiers où le gaz est recyclé.
Et pour un cosmologue,
ces galaxies ne sont pour ainsi dire que des atomes d'un univers gigantesque.
Cette image nous montre une petite partie du ciel,
si petite qu'il en faudrait une centaine identiques à celle-ci
pour couvrir la même surface que la lune dans le ciel.
Si on regardait cette région à travers un petit téléscope, on aurait l'impression qu'elle serait presque vide.
Mais là vous voyez des centaines de petites traces.
Chacune est une galaxie, grande comme la nôtre ou comme Andromède,
et si elles sont à peine visible c'est parce que leur lumière
a voyagé 10 milliards d'années avant d'arriver jusqu'à nous.
Nous voyons ces galaxies à un moment où leurs étoiles n'ont probablement pas encore de planètes.
Il y a très peu de chance qu'il y ait de la vie -- Car il n'y a pas eu un temps suffisant
pour permettre à la fusion nucléaire, au sein des étoiles, de créer du silicone, du carbone et du fer,
éléments essentiels à la naissance des planètes et à l'apparition de la vie.
Nous croyons que tout cela a émergé d'un Big Bang --
un état de l'univers extrèmement dense et chaud. Comment un Big Bang sans forme
a pu se transformer en un cosmos aussi complexe ?
Je vais vous montrer une simulation
16 puissance 10 fois plus rapide que le temps réel,
qui montre une région de l'univers où son expansion a été traçée.
Vous voyez, en même que le temps s'écoule en giga-années en bas,
comment les structures se développent par l'action de la gravité
sur de petites et denses irrégularités.
Et après 13 milliard d'années on obtient une structure
qui est assez proche de ce qu'on observe dans notre univers.
Et nous comparons ces univers simulés --
je vous en montrerai un autre exemple plus tard--
avec ce que nous voyons réellement dans le ciel.
Nous pouvons donc retracer les évènements jusqu'aux premières étapes du Big Bang,
mais nous ne savons toujours pas d'où il provient et pourquoi il a eu lieu.
C'est un challenge pour la science du 21ème siècle.
Si mon groupe de recherche avait un logo, ce serait celui-ci:
un ouroboros, avec le monde microscopique à gauche --
le monde des quanta -- et à droite
l'univers macroscopique des planètes, des étoiles et des galaxies.
Nous savons que ces deux univers sont unis --
il y a un lien entre la gauche et la droite.
Notre réalité physique est déterminée par les atomes,
et leur assemblage en molécules.
Les étoiles fonctionnent grâce aux réactions des noyaux de ces atomes.
Et nous savons depuis quelques années que les galaxies forment un tout aggloméré
par la force gravitationnelle de la fameuse matière sombre:
Immenses masses de particules beaucoup plus petites que les noyaux atomiques.
Mais nous aimerions bien faire la synthèse de ces deux mondes, symbolisée en haut.
Nous comprenons le micro-monde des quantas.
A droite vous avez le royaume de la gravité, comme décrit par Einstein.
Mais l'enjeu pour la science du 21ème siècle
est de réunir le cosmos et le monde microscopique
par une théorie unifiée -- symbolisée en haut
gastronomiquement, si l'on peut dire. (Rires)
Et tant que nous n'arriverons pas à cette synthèse,
nous ne pourrons pas comprendre les premiers moments de notre univers,
car à cette époque où notre univers lui-même était réduit à la taille d'un atome,
les effets quantiques peuvaient tout ébranler.
Donc nous avons besoin d'une théorie qui unifie le très grand et le très petit,
dont nous ne disposons pas encore.
Une des idées --
et j'affiche ce panneau danger car ce ne sont que des spéculations --
-- est que notre Big Bang ne serait pas unique.
L'idée est que notre univers en 3 dimensions
pourrait être imbriqué dans un espace de dimension supérieure,
comme on pourrait l'imaginer avec ces feuilles de papier.
Imaginez des fourmis sur l'une de ces feuilles,
pensant faire partie d'un univers à deux dimensions,
n'ayant pas conscience de l'existence d'autres fourmis sur l'autre feuille.
Il pourrait donc y avoir un autre univers séparé du nôtre par juste un millimètre,
mais dont nous ne pouvons avoir conscience car ce millimètre
est mesuré sur une quatrième dimension spatiale,
alors que nous sommes emprisonnés dans nos trois.
Nous pensons donc qu'il pourrait y avoir beaucoup d'autres réalités physiques
que celles qu'on appelle normalement notre univers --
résultant de notre Big Bang. Et voici une autre image.
En bas à droite figure notre univers
dont l'horizon ne s'étend pas au-delà,
et même ne serait qu'une bulle, en quelque sorte, dans une réalité plus vaste.
Beaucoup de gens suspectent que, tout comme nous sommes passés
d'une idée d'un système solaire unique à celle de milliards de milliards de systèmes solaires,
d'une idée d'une galaxie unique à celle d'une multitude de galaxies,
nous devons passer d'une idée d'un seul Big Bang à celle de plusieurs Big Bangs.
Peut-être que ces nombreux Big Bangs arborent
une immense variété de propriétés.
Revenons à cette image.
Il y a un challenge symbolisé en haut de l'image,
Mais vous avez un autre challenge pour la science symbolisé en bas de l'image.
Nous voulons non seulement faire la synthèse du très grand et du très petit,
mais en plus nous voulons comprendre le très complexe.
Et la chose la plus complexe c'est nous-mêmes,
à mi-chemin entre les atomes et les étoiles.
Nous dépendons des étoiles qui ont créé les atomes qui nous constituent.
Nous dépendons de la chimie qui détermine notre structure complexe.
Il est logique que nous soyons grands par rapport aux atomes,
pour pouvoir constituer cet empilement de structures complexes.
Il est logique que nous soyons petits par rapport aux étoiles et aux planètes --
sans quoi nous serions écrasés par la gravité. En réalité, nous sommes à mi-chemin.
Il faudrait autant de corps humains pour constituer le soleil
qu'il y a d'atomes en chacun de nous.
La moyenne géométrique entre la masse d'un proton
et la masse du soleil est de 50kg,
ce qui est du même ordre de grandeur que le poids de chaque personne ici.
Enfin, de la plupart d'entre vous.
La science de la complexité est probablement le challenge le plus difficile d'entre tous,
plus difficile que celui du très petit à gauche
et celui du très grand à droite.
Et c'est cette même science
qui en même temps nous éclaire sur notre compréhension du monde biologique,
et également transforme notre monde plus rapidement que jamais.
Qui plus est, elle provoque de nouveaux types de changements.
J'en arrive à la seconde partie de mon exposé,
et à mon livre "Notre Dernier Siècle" (Our Final Century).
Si je n'avais pas l'humilité légendaire des anglais, je parlerais moi-même de mon livre,
et j'ajouterais qu'il est disponible en édition de poche.
(Rires)
Et aux USA il s'intitule "Notre Dernière Heure"
car les américains aiment les plaisirs immédiats.
(Rires)
Mon idée est que dans ce siècle,
non seulement la science va changer le monde plus rapidement que jamais auparavant,
mais de manières différentes et nouvelles.
Des médicaments sur mesure, des modifications génétiques, l'intelligence artificielle,
peut-être même des implants dans nos cerveaux,
pourraient changer les êtres humains eux-mêmes. Et l'espèce humaine,
physiquement et psychologiquement, n'a pas changé depuis des milliers d'années.
Elle pourrait se transformer pendant ce siècle.
C'est une nouveauté dans notre histoire.
Et l'impact de l'homme sur l'environnement -- l'effet de serre,
les extinctions de masse, etc. -- est sans précédent également.
Ce nouveau siècle est donc en lui-même un challenge.
Les technologies biologiques et cybernétiques sont bienveillantes pour l'environnement,
car elles ouvrent des perspectives merveilleuses,
tout en réduisant la pression sur l'énergie et les ressources.
Mais elles auront leurs côté sombre.
Dans notre monde interconnecté, une technologie novatrice peut donner le pouvoir
à un fanatique,
ou à un hurluberlu avec le même état d'esprit que ceux qui crèent des virus informatiques,
de déclencher un désastre.
D'ailleurs, une catastrophe pourrait simplement provenir d'une mésaventure technique --
l'erreur plutôt que la terreur.
Même une probabilité infime de catastrophe est inacceptable
si elle avait des conséquences globales.
En fait, il y a quelques années, Bill Joy a écrit un article
où il exprimait sa grande inquiétude à l'idée que des robots pourraient nous contrôler, etc.
Je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui,
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il proposait une solution simple.
Il appelait cela la renonciation minutieuse.
Il voulait qu'on abandonne les sciences dangereuses
et qu'on ne garde que les bon aspects. C'est d'une naïveté absurde pour deux raisons.
D'abord, toute découverte scientifique a des conséquences à la fois bénéfiques
et à la fois dangereuses.
Ensuite, quand un scientifique fait une découverte,
il ou elle n'a en général aucune idée des applications qui vont en découler.
Cela signifie que nous devons accepter les risques
si nous voulons profiter des bienfaits de la science.
Nous devons accepter le fait qu'il y a des dangers.
Et je pense que nous pouvons nous inspirer de ce qui s'est passé
juste après la seconde guerre mondiale, lorsque les scientifiques du nucléaire
qui ont participé à l'élaboration de la bombe atomique,
souvent, ont été les premiers à déployer leurs efforts
pour alerter le monde des dangers de ces armes.
Ils s'inspiraient non pas du jeune Einstein,
qui nous a apporté la Relativité, mais du vieux Einstein,
l'icône des posters et des T-Shirts,
dont les efforts scientifiques n'ont pas réussi à aboutir à l'unification des lois physiques.
Il était en avance sur son temps. Mais il servait de guide moral,
d'inspiration pour les scientifiques qui souhaitaient un contrôle des armements nucléaires.
Et peut-être l'un des êtres les plus admirables,
une personne que j'ai eu le privilège de connaître, Joe Rotblat.
Son bureau est tout autant en désordre, comme vous pouvez le constater.
Il a 96 ans, et a fondé le mouvement Pugwash.
Il a persuadé Einstein, peu avant sa mort,
de signer le fameux mémorandum de Bertrand Russel.
Il est à lui seul un modèle pour la conscience scientifique.
Et je pense que pour maîtriser les avancées scientifiques,
pour choisir quelles portes ouvrir et quelles portes laisser fermer,
il nous faut des personnes aujourd'hui à l'image de Joseph Rotblat.
Nous avons besoin non seulement de physiciens engagés,
mais également de biologistes, d'experts informatiques,
et d'écologistes.
Et je pense que les entrepreneurs diplômés et indépendants
ont une obligation particulière car ils disposent de plus de liberté
que ceux au service d'un gouvernement,
ou que les employés d'une société sujets à la pression commerciale.
J'ai écrit mon livre, "Notre dernier siècle"
en tant que scientifique de manière générale. Mais il y a un point, je pense,
qui, rédigé en tant que cosmologue, offre une perspective speciale,
c'est qu'il offre une conscience de notre immense futur.
L'incroyable longueur du temps nécessaire à l'évolution passée
fait maintenant partie de la culture populaire --
en dehors des communautés américaines créationnistes, tout du moins --
(rires)
mais la plupart des gens, même ceux qui connaissent bien l'évolution,
ne se doutent pas que nous avons encore plus de temps devant nous.
Le soleil brille depuis 4,5 milliards d'années,
mais il brillera de cette manière encore 6 milliards d'années, avant d'épuiser son énergie.
Sur ce schéma, nous sommes à mi-chemin.
Nous avons donc encore 6 milliards d'années avant que
toute vie sur Terre soit vaporisée.
On a tendance à penser que des humains seront là,
et assisteront à la mort du soleil,
mais la vie et l'intelligence qui existeront à ce moment-là
seront aussi différentes de nous que nous sommes différents des bactéries.
L'intelligence et la complexité
ont encore d'immenses développements à venir, sur Terre et probablement bien au-delà.
Nous sommes donc au début de l'émergence de la complexité
sur notre planète et au-delà.
Si on ramène la vie de la Terre à une seule année,
Disons de sa création en Janvier jusqu'à Décembre,
le 21ème siècle représente un quart de seconde en Juin --
une toute petite fraction de l'année.
Mais même dans cette perspective cosmique condensée,
notre siècle est très, très spécial.
C'est le premier où les humains peuvent se transformer eux-même et leur planète.
Ainsi que je le disais,
ce ne seront pas des humains qui assisteront à la mort du Soleil,
ce seront des créatures aussi différentes de nous que nous sommes différents des bactéries.
Quand Einstein mourut en 1955,
un des témoignages les plus marquants de sa renommée fut ce dessin
de Herblock paru dans le Washington Post.
Il est écrit sur le panneau: "Albert Einstein a vécu ici."
J'aimerais terminer avec une image inspirée de ce dessin.
Nous connaissons cette image depuis 40 ans:
la fragile beauté des continents, des océans et des nuages,
contrastant avec le paysage lunaire stérile
sur lequel les astronautes ont laissé leurs empreintes.
Supposons que des extra-terrestres aient observé notre petit point bleu pâle
depuis un cosmos lointain, non pas pendant 40 ans,
mais depuis les 4,5 milliards d'années de l'histoire de notre Terre.
Qu'auraient-ils vu ?
Pendant presque tout ce laps de temps immense,
l'apparence de la Terre n'aura changé que très progressivement.
Les seuls changements abrupts
auront été les impacts d'astéroïdes majeurs ou des super-éruptions volcaniques.
A part ces brefs traumatismes, rien n'est arrivé brusquement.
Les masses continentales se sont promenés.
Les calottes glacières sont allées et venues.
Des successions d'espèces ont émergé, évolué et se sont éteintes.
Mais pendant une minuscule fraction de l'histoire de la Terre,
le dernier millionième, en quelques milliers d'années,
l'implantation de la végétation s'est modifiée beaucoup plus rapidement qu'auparavant.
Cela marque le démarrage de l'agriculture.
Les changements se sont accélérés avec l'augmentation de la population humaine.
Puis d'autres évènements se sont produit encore plus brutalement.
En l'espace de 50 ans --
soit un centième de millionième de l'age de la Terre --
le taux de dioxide de carbone dans l'atmosphère a commencé à augmenter,
et incroyablement rapidement.
La planète est devenue un émetteur intense d'ondes radio --
toutes les transmissions de toutes les TV, téléphones portables
et radars. Et quelque chose est apparu.
Des objets métalliques -- de taille très réduite, quelques tonnes tout au plus --
se sont élevés en orbite autour de la Terre.
Certains ont voyagé vers des lunes et des planètes.
Une race avancée d'extra-terrestres
qui regarderait notre système solaire à distance
pourrait prédire sans problème le destin funeste de la Terre dans 6 milliards d'années.
Mais auraient-ils pu prévoir ce sursaut sans précédent
à peine à mi-chemin de la vie de la Terre ?
Ces altérations issues des êtres humains
qui occupent au total moins d'un millionnième de l'age actuel de la Terre
et qui semblent se dérouler à une vitesse fulgurante ?
S'ils continuaient leur veille,
de quoi ces aliens hypothétiques seraient-ils témoin
dans les 100 prochaines années ?
Est-ce qu'un spasme condamnera le futur de la Terre ?
Ou bien la biosphère se stabilisera-t-elle ?
Ou est-ce que certains objets métalliques décollant de la Terre
iront créer de nouvelles oasis de vie post-humaine ailleurs ?
La science pratiquée par le jeune Einstein perdurera
aussi longtemps que notre civilisation. Mais pour que notre civilisation survive,
il nous faudra la sagesse du vieil Einstein --
son humanisme global et sa vision à long terme.
Et ce qui se passera dans ce siècle crucial
résonera dans le futur lointain, et peut-être bien au-delà de la Terre,
bien au-delà de la Terre ainsi que représenté ici.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)